you seem like a very law-abiding fellow
that you recently got to do some trouble
at a bank and I'm curious how could that
happen you don't seem like the type I
know I got in a lot of trouble actually
is that true yeah so I was at the bank
and I was thinking of one of my friends
who's saying Orion and you know I told
you to single for a while and I saw the
teller working who's just I don't know
attractive woman and in my mind I go I'm
gonna set him up on a blind date you
know mm-hmm so that's without talking to
her or anything no dear he was wearing a
ring yeah I think yeah that's it no ring
on her hand so I call him I go I think I
have a perfect blind date person for you
she works at the bank and I think you
should go on a date and he's like okay
do you have a picture of her and I'm
like yeah next to the picture of my
gardener and my yeah I just keep petals
of random have a picture of her he goes
what I'd like to see her before I agree
to this and I'm like I'm telling you
she's beautiful he's like no I need to
see her I'm like okay just forget it
then and then like a week later I just
I'm back at the bank I'm waiting in line
I'm on my phone I see her and I just
pull up my phone I snap a couple
pictures of her
and I leave and then I get a call and
there's like you were just at the bank
and I go yeah and thanks for the follow
up call I appreciate I like your bank
and they're like no we're from the
Security Division of Wells Fargo and why
we have photos and videos of you taking
pictures in the bank today why are you
doing that and I go I panic I was like
do you think I'm trying to rob the bank
and they go I don't know are you yeah
that's a fair question at this point I
guess but I'm so nervous I just go nah
wasn't I'm not trying to rob the bank I
was just taking pictures of that one
teller to send to my friend uh-huh and
they're like what and I go well I don't
know I thought she was single they go we
don't appreciate our employees privacy
being violated I go yeah I'm sorry
you're right there go delete it and I go
okay and then they go and now you're on
the list
and I go what list and they go it's a
potential threat list that all banks
share is this real this is real and so
they're like you're just permanently a
threat to all banks and I'm like am I
allowed to bank here anymore and they go
you have to work it out with that branch
so then I have to go into the branch I
sit down with the manager and I'm like
hey I tell him the whole story I go I'm
sorry can i still bank here and she goes
yeah I don't know he talked about and I
was like what I go whoa I thought that
had to clear it with you guys she goes
you should probably clear with Natasha
that's the girl
the actual teller hi Natasha so
then I go sit with Natasha and I tell
her the whole thing and I go I'm sorry
you know just trying to stay up on a
date
do you mind if I still bank here and she
was like no and I go cool do you do want
to go on a date with my friend and she
goes do you have a picture
I actually do I was like yeah yeah I
showed her and she goes not my type you
still on the list on a federal that's
amazing thread watch it's very good
that's why I don't then more PayPal
anybody I'm not allowed to you know
that's that's an incredible story yeah
yeah you idiot yeah
you